فعلا سيكون كذلك لكن تكشف قبل قليل في
اسرائيل ان رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو
كان قد افشل مقترحا قطريا وافقت عليه حماس
ونقله اليه رئيس جهاز الموساد دادي برنيع
خلال اجتماع ومباحثات باريس قبل نحو
اسبوعين نص على ان يكون هناك وقفا لاطلاق
النار خلال الايام السبعه التي ستفصل بين
كل مرحله ومرحله من عمليه صفقات تبادل
الاسرى الثلاثه المقترحه وان نتنياهو افشل
ذلك ورفضه ومنع رئيس المساد من اطلاع مجلس
الحرب عليه وعندما انحى عليه
باللائمة يستطيع ان يتفوه بشيء الا باذن
من رئيس الوزراء هذا التطور يشير الى
التصريحات الناريه التي كان نتنياهو قد
ادلى بها خلال اليومين الماضيين وتحدث
فيها عن انه لن يوقف الحرب حتى يكون
هناك انتصار مطلق على حد تعبيره وهو ما
يشير الى وفق الاسرائيليين الى ان نتنياهو
يواصل توجيه كلامه بالاساس الى قاعده
الانتخابيه وان مصلحته السياسيه الحزبيه
وتثبيت توليفته اليمينيه تتقدم على كل شيء
مباحثات بلينكن اليوم سيبدا بعد قليل مع
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو وستركز من جديد على
تطورات الموقف الاسرائيلي من العرض الذي
قدمته حركه حماس ونقلته دوله قطر امس خلال
وجود وزير الخارجيه بلينكن في الدوحه و
حسب هذه المعلومات فان العرض وهو ياتي كرد
على اتفاق الاطار العام الذي انتهت اليه
مباحثات باريس بخصوص ابرام صفقه
تبادل للاسرى وكذلك هدنه طويله الامد فان
في اسرائيل وحسب ما نقلته الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه الرسميه عن مصادر في ديوان
رئاسه الوزراء قالوا بانهم سيردون على ذلك
بعد دراسته خلال الايام المقبله وان
الموقف حاليا يبدو كانه منقسم منقسم بين
من يرى فيه نقطه بدايه وبين من يحاول ان
يعتبره في مجمله بانه رفضا من قبل حماس
لاطار العام
للاتفاق التي انتهت اليه مباحثات باريس
بلينكن سيبحث مع نتنياهو بهذا الخصوص
تطورات هذه المساله والموقف الاسرائيلي
بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال الى المطلب
الامريكي بضروره ان تتوفر يتوفر تصور
اسرائيلي سياسي لليوم التالي للحرب ومسار
هذه الحرب في هذه المرحله من خلال محاوله
تجنيب المدنيين الفلسطينيين خاصه في منطقه
رفح وغرب خانيونس من ويلاتها بالاضافه الى
مضاعفه وسلاسه ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
الى قطاع غزه والتي عرقل خلال الايام
الماضيه ناشطون يمينيون موالون لنتن
وحكومته هذه الامور الرئيسيه التي سيبحثها
بلينكن مع الجانب الاسرائيلي وسيبدا
بنتنياهو ومن ثم تتوالى مع اخرين استبقت
هذه الزياره خلافات بين اسرائيل وواشنطن
يعني اقرها نتنياهو بنفسه وهجوم تعرض له
الرئيس بايدن من قبل قيادات ومسؤولين
اسرائيليين منهم بن غفير اجواء الاجواء
الت التي تستبق هذه الزياره في ظل الاعلان
عن هذه
الخلافات هذه التهجمات والاساءه للرئيس
الامريكي جاءت من بن كفير وابن ابن كفير
ايضا ابنه الذي نشر تغريده اساء بها
للرئيس الامريكي ثم اضطر الى مسحها
والاعتذار وكذلك اعتذر والده عنها لكن
واضح بان بلينكن يصل الى اسرائيل في زياره
هي السادسه منذ بدايه الحرب على غزه والتي
تدخل اليوم يومها المئ و24
وا تاتي ايضا على خلفيه التوتر المحتدم
بين نتنياهو والرئيس بايدن لان الرئيس
بايدن ووفق كافه المعلومات ثقته برئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو مهزوزه حتى
بشكل كبير وانه يرى بان نتنياهو لا يتصرف
وفق ما ينفع مصالح الولايات المتحده ايضا
وانه يريد لهذه الحرب ان تصل حدودها ما
نشر من قبل نتنياهو
ومصادره ضد الرئيس الامريكي يوحي بان
نتنياهو انما يريد تمديد الحرب من اجل ان
تصل الى مرحله الانتخابات الامريكيه في
نوفمبر المقبل على امل ان تعيد الرئيس
ترامب الى السلطه وهو ما سيسهل على
نتنياهو سياسته لكي يمضي بها بالنسبه
لقطاع غزه سواء من خلال التهجير القصري
وهو ما يرفضه الامريكيون هنا جمله وتفصيله
او من خلال محاوله استدامه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي واعاده الاستيطان وهو ما يعمل
عليه حلفائه من الصهيونيه الدينيه وقوه
يهوديه بلايل سموتريتش وبن كفير واللذان
جاهرا وعقدا مؤتمرا خصيصا لذلك تهجمات بن
كفير وابنه وا اوساط اخرى حول نتنياهو ضد
الرئيس الامريكي ادخلت التوتر المزيد من
التوتر للعلاقات بين نتنياهو وبين الرئيس
بايدن وهو ما اثار قلقا متزايدا في
الاوساط الاسرائيليه خاصه وان الرئيس
بايدن قدم من المساعدات لاسرائيل الكثير
الكثير منذ بدايه هذه الحرب سواء كانت
بالذخيره والسلاح او المواقف السياسيه
الداعمه او التمويل وتقديم الدعم في كافه
المنابر والمحافل هذا التوتر على خلفيته
يصل بلينكن الى اسرائيل واليوم في
اجتماعاته مع نتنياهو قد تتضح الصوره اكثر
فيما اذا تتجه الصوره نحو تبديد هذا
التوتر او تاجيج شكرا وليد